This is Radiolab on Jad
Abumrad. A couple days ago,
Joe Frank passed away one of
the greats in our business.
Huge inspiration for me. But a
guy whose work you may not know,
he was one of the originals.
Nobody told stories like Joe Frank,
nobody tells stories like Joe Frank,
no one. He, he is still anyhow,
you know what I'm gonna do.
I want to take this podcast to play for
you a little bit of his work cause it's
so good. It's so good.
And also play for you.
A few conversations I've had recently
about Joe Frank and the impact of that
work starting with, um,
a conversation I had with Brooke
Gladstone from on the media.
She recently interviewed me about, uh,
the impact that show had on radio lab,
which is significant.
So let's start there.
This is an excerpt of a conversation that
I had with Brooke Gladstone that they
use for on the media. And I
believe it starts with a clip. Hey,
let me play a clip or maybe a
couple of them get your reaction
[inaudible]
when you hug people goodbye
after a social event,
perhaps a dinner party
or a gallery opening,
there was always that moment when they
squeeze you more forcefully than before.
A polite way of letting you
know they are about to withdraw.
Usually the one who disengages
first is the one who cares less.
When this used to happen to me,
I felt rejected and humiliated.
I'd come home with a lonely,
sick feeling and that's why in order to
assume the power position and gain the
psychological advantage, I
now hug people very briefly,
perhaps one or two seconds
before freeing myself.
Sometimes if I detect any resistance,
I'll push the person away.
In one instance,
I caused a woman to fall backwards
over a chair injuring her back,
which led to her hospitalization,
but I have no choice.
It was a matter of self preservation.
That is classic Joe
Frey. It's really, really
good writing. You know, he
writes these like scenarios.
They're like demented talk
of the towns in the way,
like they're just these little
fragments of dark experience,
which are beautifully realized.
Very vivid, kind of funny,
but kind of also troubling.
How do you think he influenced you?
Because you are always a great
producer, always technically adept.
You had tons of musical
composition training,
you understood the rhythmic
possibilities of radio.
What did he do that you don't think
you could've done without him?
It's a lot of different things.
This was way at the beginning for me when
radio lab was just a three hour thing
on the am station one back, how far
we're going back to the stone age.
So January, February, 2002 somewhere
around there. Really at the beginning.
And everybody here who knows the
beginning of radio lab knows that I didn't
deserve that show. It was just too soon.
And I didn't know what I was doing.
I didn't have a style. I had this,
I had the like unfortunate thing that
we all had back in 2002 is that I would
just want it to be IRA glass. Everybody
wanted to be hourglass. Right?
And I was still trying to figure
out like, okay, so who am I?
What do I want my stuff to sound like?
And so I would every Sunday night
I'd have to put it three hours.
And it was an anthology
show at that point.
And it was literally take the
best documentaries from the BBC,
the CBC in Canada, the ABC in
Australia, radio, Netherlands,
all the stuff and packaged them
into three continuous hours.
And I would sort of narrate in
and out of different segments.
And so from eight to 11 I'd be playing
my show and I was bored hopping at the
time, which means I wasn't just making
the thing, but I had to sit at the board,
hit play on the CD,
and then between hour one an
hour to an hour to an hour three,
I would have to say the weather, right?
So I was doing the whole
thing and after me,
Joe Frank would come on and
he was part of my shift.
And every time I'd just be like,
what the F is this stuff?
I would just be sitting there listening
to him and just like amazed and like
mentally taking notes, being like,
oh, this guy has a feel and a,
there's a surreality and a disorienting
newness to his stuff that I just just
really fascinated by and I was like,
oh, I want to, I want to do that.
Can we play that one that
we said that we can't play?
[inaudible] there was a time when I
danced on a street corner dressed as a
chicken. My job was to draw attention
to a furniture store down the block.
One evening when my shift was over
still wearing my chicken outfit,
I walked into a bar across the
street. I ordered a Bombay Martini,
straight up olives on the side.
A prostitute sat down next to me.
She was young Willoway at a
far away look in her eyes.
Her name was Meredith. We
talked about our careers,
the importance of networking,
setting goals, focus.
Then I excused myself,
walked into the men's room,
entered a stall and sat down on the
toilet and had a bowel movement.
The broken tube and half of it
was still hanging out of me.
So I had to wipe myself 50
times repeatedly checking
to see if there was more
left on the toilet paper and
written on the wall with the words,
know that someone is suffering anonymously
and unknown and that by the time you
read this,
I'll be dead.
Oh, that's good. That's really good. Wow.
There's nothing wrong with
playing that clip. Actually.
He's not using any bad
words. True. I mean,
there's no FCC violations
there and it's simply growth.
And yet you tell me that there was this
person on the planet too that hasn't,
Joe Frank always had the quality of like
he's coming from inside your head out
and then back in again. He
has that kind of quality,
which it sounds like he's somehow
like the voice in your head,
but broadcast back into your head. Um,
I, there's something about that quality,
which like I, that's what I want from
the radio. It's what I want from podcast.
I want someone to be speaking
from inside me in a way.
Have you ever talked about Joe Frank too?
I give this talk 30 40 times a year
where I have like an extended Joe Frank
excerpt. I have an image of Joe Frank
that I show a, yeah, all the time.
The vast majority of our listeners
of the people listening to this,
I'm going to have to assume they never
heard of Joe Frank and he was always
available on podcast,
but he was like this mystery to people
who weren't willing to sort of follow the
breadcrumbs to him. You
know, I'll tell you,
I mean when I give this talk that I,
that I often give and I go through the
series of people who've influenced me.
I'll always ask any Joe Frank fans in
the house, these will be like audiences,
but 2020 500 people and like
one time someone clapped.
One time I remember like there was a
clap in the far right and I was like,
oh my God, a Joe Frank Fan.
It always broke my heart a little bit
because no one ever knew his stuff.
Like amongst us, our little sort of
posse radio people. He's a legend,
but nobody on the outside
ever knew him. You know,
this is going to be their chance. Yeah.
[inaudible]
last night I dreamt I
was lost on an elevator.
All the floors were the same.
Then I realized the elevator
was moving horizontally,
so I tried another
elevator, but the express,
but it just got me more lost faster.
People kept getting on and getting off.
They were all wearing green galls over
their heads and we're smoking ice cream
cones. I said, please let
me off of 39th street,
and the conductor said,
this is 35th street.
You'll have to walk three
blocks and take the escalator.
But when I got to the escalator,
it was just a phone booth.
So I made a call. I called my father,
I said hello and lost on 39th street
looking for an escalator and I can't find
it anywhere. And he said,
I'll be right there and there he wants.
And the phone booth started moving forward
very slowly with my father and I in
it. And I didn't know where it
was going or why. And he said,
don't be afraid. This phone booth
will take us home. And I said,
but we have no home. And he said,
we live on the eighth floor
apartment. Why? And I said,
why? And he said, yes.
[inaudible]
that was a condensed version
of a conversation I had
with Brooke Gladstone for
on the media.
You can find the full
conversation on the media.org.
Okay,
well return with one more Joe Frank
recollection in just a moment.
This is Michael Barrels
from Portland, Oregon.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology and the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
Hey, uh, Simon Adler here. Uh,
I'm one of the producers here at Radiolab
and I wanted to take a quick second to
tell you about something that, uh, that
I think is pretty interesting that,
that we make here, uh, besides
the show. So we have a newsletter,
which I know everyone
does, but hear me out.
Unlike a lot of other
newsletters out there, uh,
we don't waste your time by just blabbing
about what our next release will be or
begging you for money. Uh, actually
we, we do a little bit of that,
but what we also do is each
time a new episode drops,
we send you a list of staff picks,
essentially a collection of things.
The folks here who make this show have
come across recently and are excited
about, uh, they range from books and
music to TV shows, youtube clips,
art exhibits, blogs.
It's sort of a repository for this
stuff that's got us interested.
But for whatever reason, uh, we're not
sure how to turn into a radio story.
So if that sounds
interesting to you at all,
I hope you'll sign up for our newsletter.
It's free and you can sign up
in about just 30 seconds at
radiolab.org/newsletter or even easier.
Just text our l news as in radio lab news
two seven zero one zero one that's RL
news to seven zero one
zero one and thanks.
This is Jonah from Batavia, Illinois.
Radiolab is supported by zoom.us video
conferencing has changed the way we do
business. Meet. Happy anytime,
anywhere with zoom
connecting members across the
globe. Imagine seeing 25 people on
the screen at once in digital video.
Share anything, a file, a video,
a photo via desktop, laptop,
tablet, or mobile.
Visit zoom.us to set up your free account
today and meet happy with zoom video
communications zoom.us. Hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Culligan water
from bubble baths to doggy bowls plans
to your favorite pasta, your whole
home drinks, water. It makes sense.
Therefore to want that water to be
cleaner and soft and tastes great.
With a Culligan water system,
you could enjoy the best water softening
and filtration technology tailored to
what your home needs.
And this means you can focus on providing
your friends and your family the best
of everything without having to
think twice about your water.
To learn more about Culligan Water's
whole home water solutions. Visit.
Hey culligan.com and you can
give your people Culligan water.
Hi, this is John Roderick
from the rock band,
the long winters and I'm Ken Jennings
from the syndicated Chris show jeopardy.
We have a podcast called omnibus.
It's a time capsule of our era and we
put a new entry in the ground every
Tuesday and Thursday.
Listen on Apple podcasts or wherever
you get your podcasts and subscribe to.
Never miss a single episode.
I'm jet I boom Rod, this is radio lab a.
We're paying tribute to
Joe Frank in this podcast.
Joe Unfortunately lost a battle with
colon cancer just a few days ago after my
conversation with Brooke
Gladstone from on the media. Um,
I ended up having later that same day
another conversation about Joe Frank,
this time with IRA glass from
this American life. Hello.
Hey. How's it going, man? It's
going okay. It's good. Okay.
We can do better line reading. There
were two entirely different. Okay.
It's just done for the purposes
of this conversation I'm doing.
I'm doing just all right. Hey,
did you know Joe Frank? No,
I had one interaction with
Joe Frank, which was, um,
it was almost perfectly
Joe Frank in that, uh,
I met him once at third coast and he,
I asked him something and he looked at
me for a long time and then just walked
away without speaking. And that
was my one Joe Frank interaction.
So do you remember what you asked him?
I think I might have said something
utterly like not my place cause I had just
started the show and I was like, Hey,
if you have any work that you
want to like, you know, get on,
get on the show, let me know.
And he just looked at me like you
have the goal and just walked away.
And so that was it. Yeah.
Yeah. That's showed you.
So what do you remember about him?
I'm curious like what, what you saw,
cause you, you worked with him,
right? Yeah. Basically when I was,
when I was 20, uh,
I had my first paid job at MPR and I
was the production assistant to this guy
whose job it was to invent new
ways to, to do radio for NPR.
And he had a regular show and he would
do different things in different weeks
and,
and he brought Joe Frank down from New
York and that was the thing we were doing
for awhile.
And I was Joe's production assistant
as my very first paid job at NPR.
And I had never heard them on the
radio. I mean, he wasn't like, you know,
on national radio. So, um,
they have like a few various
specific memories for sure. And um,
the best way I can explain it is like, um,
I've had the experience a number of times
over the years where people tried to
tell me like, oh, the first
time I heard your show was this.
And generally the thing they're
trying to say to me is like,
I didn't know that the radio could
do that. You know what I mean?
Like I didn't realize it. Like, oh, radio
could be like, tell a story like that.
No, it feel like this. And I
myself had that exact experience.
And the person who I had it
with was Joe Frank. And um,
and I remember there was a day early on
and I was standing in the old control
room at MPRs original studios. Like
the original two studios they had,
there was a studio one studio two on
the first floor of 2020 m street and we
were in studio two and I was standing
by the reel to reel tape machine,
you know, the Bank of them.
And I remember Joe was telling one of
his stories and I remember feeling like,
Oh, I've never, I've
never heard this before.
I just remember feeling like, like this,
like this thing, like I, and, and, and,
and it just sorta like to feel like
totally caught up in a story and you don't
exactly know why you're so caught up with
it and you don't know where it's going
and, uh, and you just want to stay
with it in the sound of his voice.
He's such like an
incredible radio performer,
like much better than you
or me. You know what I mean?
Like do you remember what the story
was that you were listening to?
I don't remember which
specific story it was.
I do remember I have gone back because
there was one story in particular called
the elevator.
Then in fact,
I've gone and dug up that I
remember at the time I thought like,
this is it. This sums up the whole
thing and literally what it is,
I'm riding up the elevator of my
building is he gets on an elevator.
I'm standing there sharing the small
space with a terrific looking girl.
He totally gets a crush on this
woman, but I feel shy, uncomfortable.
I scratch my head, I sigh,
I gaze up at the numbers of the floors,
lighting up one after another and he
starts to imagine their life together at
everything that they will be.
He seems like the kind of person I really
like and he cannot bring himself to
stand there silently, not looking
at each other, say a word to her,
and so he pulls out
something from his pocket.
I reach into my pocket and draw out
a scrap of paper, which I unfold.
It turns out to be a cash
register tape from the A and P,
but I scrutinize it as if it's very
important before putting it back in my
pocket. That's a detail of the
stray I remember seeming so real.
It has a guy very magnetic forward
motion and it's like four or five minutes
long and the entire thing happens in
the elevator and he would always just
describing the floors going up
and all the feelings he has.
You go through your life
looking and looking,
and sometimes you see her though
the woman you might've loved with,
who might've loved you at a bus stop. You
know, in a museum across a smoky room,
at a party in the lobby of a theater
online at the supermarket in an elevator.
When she leaves in a panic, you want to
run after her calling out, stop. Stop.
It's me. The person you were
meant for. Don't you recognize me?
Don't I look familiar? I
may seem like a stranger,
but I'm the person you've been
waiting for the one in your dreams,
but you just stand there
and watch her leave.
This happens to me with a different
woman about once each day.
And I remember
when I was 20 hearing that and
being like, this is it. This,
this guy is doing a thing. Like I want
to know, I want to know how you do this.
Yes. For me the equivalent thing was have
you heard his rent? A family trilogy?
No. God, I'd be hard pressed
to, to summarize the story,
but it's essentially it's this whole
world in which families can be rented. Uh,
for occasions. Well, I saw this ad
and Annie said,
rent a family. We have certain um,
package programs where an individual
can experience over the course of a 12
month period. A pretty
considerable range of, of families.
Hi. Hi Christa.
It's your father from
the agency come here.
And it's all like in his very documentary
format and it's done really well.
So you actually sometimes like aren't
totally sure that what you're hearing is a
drama. It sounds super real.
We kind of deny that the society is, is,
seems to be speeding up
before our very eyes.
The whole idea of renting things,
it has to do with the people's desire
to not have a permanent commitment to
them.
I think it's important to recognize
the depth of loneliness that,
uh, must be addressed to
you and I, and in the end it
doesn't resolve at all.
You'll just left with like 12 different
feelings that you don't even know what
to do with. I mean, I think in a way
like that's, that's what he represents.
You're like thrown in the middle of the
action and it's gritty and you don't
understand. It's kind of dark and
it's not all going to get resolved.
All the answers aren't going to be given
to you and you're going to have like
weird feelings. You don't
know what to do with.
And often it's going to overreach
and it's not even going to work.
But it was still kind of cool. You know,
like all of that is completely content.
It's completely seventies
film turned into radio.
So what is it that you think you took
with you from Joe Frank and put into this
American life? I mean, there are
a couple of things. Honestly,
the first thing is just what he
gave me the most important thing,
which was desire to do
it. You know what I mean?
Like hearing him made me want to make
stories and then I spent over a decade
trying to figure out how to do
it with facts and with reporting.
The thing that started me with that
ambition was him. So that's one thing.
A second thing is I'm just,
the way he would use music and the way
that the music would pull the story
forward and create a mood, but also kind
of like push you into the dream of it.
The notion that you'd use music
as a kind of cinematic scoring,
which is not the way, you know,
music would be used in old time radio
dramas and certainly not the way music was
being used on anything on NPR. And, um,
the way he uses music is so built into
me that a couple of years after this
American life was on the air, Joe
was already living out in California,
had been for years and still
doing his show. And uh,
like mutual friends let me know
like Joe is so angry with you.
And I was like, why is Joe so angry
with me? You know what I mean?
Cause he was my like, he was
like, why is he so angry?
And then it turned out that Joe thought
that I was listening to his show and
stealing the music. Oh yeah. And then
got in touch with him and he's just like,
it's so petty. He said, this is so petty.
You could be choosing any music and
you're listening to my show. He's like,
it takes me so long to find decent music
and I edited so carefully, you know,
it's such a part of the identity of the
show and that you just listen to my show
and rip me off, like do a little
work brother. And I was like, Joe,
it's so much worse than
that. Like the fact,
it's like I haven't had your show in
years. I haven't heard it. I'm so sorry.
And what happened is I just
learned how to use music from you.
And so when Pat Mathenia
comes out with a new record,
I hear the same track you do and
hear the same possibility in it.
And I just do the same thing because
like it's so built into who I am.
So in a way like I am
totally stealing from you,
but I swear I didn't know it. No.
Did you ever, did you ever like
land that in a good place with him?
He was fine at the end of it, I think.
I think it was just something about the,
it was just, it seems so like, it seems
so small to him, you know what I mean?
Like what, you're listening to my showing,
you're stealing my music. Like what,
what's the matter with you? You know
what I mean? Just seem cheap. Yeah.
So there was that. And um, what
else carries forward from him?
I mean, I mean it's, it's
honestly there's a thing or two that he
does that I have never figured out how
to imitate that in the back of my mind
I still feel like I'm going to steal
that. And one of them is this
thing that came up last week.
I was talking to Parker, one of the,
like the younger producers here and she
was talking about a thing she wanted to
do and kind of a moment she really loves
and she used to be a film professor and
is like a super cinematic thing. She was
shooting for us. Like, you know what,
you should really listen to this Guy
Joe Frank at, you never heard of him.
And I downloaded last week I bought
and downloaded a the 80 yard run.
Which have you heard that one? No,
no one I haven't heard. Oh my God,
it's a super early one. In fact,
I think it's just an air check of one
of his WBAI broadcast before he was
national. I think it's an
actual live radio show.
I'm done late at night and it's just
him and a microphone with music.
And he's telling this story of
what he keeps referring to as,
because I like to call it my infamous
80 yard run is a rather twisted,
convoluted tale.
Now, before I get to the
full story of my ADR run,
I hope that you will bear with me.
There's a few things
you need to know first.
And the first thing you need
to know is about this fight
between Luis Rodriguez and
Ruben, Hurricane Carter.
You know, it's, there's a lot of that.
And then he tells you like a series of
professional fights that happened over
the years and tells them so well
he absorbed an awesome, terrible beating,
standing propped up unconscious.
And then there comes a
point where he's like,
you're like six or eight minutes
into the thing and he says, um,
but before I can tell you that part of
the story you need to in this next thing.
And I will tell you that
after a brief interlude during
which I will drink some tea
[inaudible]
and they're like, what are you, like the
music comes up and then he just leaves.
And I was like, oh my God.
And like I've spent 30 years trying
to figure out how to steal that.
You want to have a team moment. I don't
even know how to do it. I honestly,
I honestly,
I don't know man. I mean, I mean like,
like I'm going to figure it out,
but first I'm going to
go make myself some tea.
[inaudible]
that's IRA glass from this
American life thanks to him.
Thanks also to brook class, tune
from on the media and to Sarah, Cari,
and Kelly prime of the more perfect
crew who produced this tribute.
Also a very special
thanks to Michael Story.
If you want to hear excerpts
of Joe Frank's work,
which I would highly recommend,
go to Joe frank.com his
entire archive is there.
We'll also link you to it
from radiolab.org and one
of the things that you will
hear, I think if you listen and
Ira and I talked about this,
is that even though he's a guy who has
inspired so many of us to get into the
business of telling stories,
nobody sounds like him still
because it's completely impossible to
imitate you into the hundreds of thousands
of podcasts that are happening now.
There's nobody doing anything as
um,
caring and competent
at the same time. Yeah.
Like literally like it's so singular,
you can't really imitate it very well.
And I'm personally not one
who, who believes that matters.
Like if your work lives on
past you, you know what I mean?
Like I feel like fuck people in
the future, you know what I mean?
Like these are radio shows, you know,
like, like they meant to be enjoyed, like,
you know, like right now.
And then like if no one ever listens to
them again after we're gone. Like, well,
fuck them. Anyway, like walking around
and being alive while we're dead.
First of all,
fuck all those people being alive and
having sandwiches and meeting for lunch
while we're dead and not existing.
Like I hate them already.
They can fuck themselves. Um,
but it seems if it seems
sad that, that, that,
that other people like won't know this
weird thing that I know is so special,
you know, like, he's so outpacing
everybody. Even now, even now,
there's like this army of people making
podcasts and trying to invent something
that's like nobody else
is doing. He still is.
He still has outpaced every
single one of them from the grave.
That's a perfect place
to end. Okay. Bye. Bye.